with on your weird mind I'm putting
together a team
I mean you are
that was beautiful
these things are gonna keep coming you
get technical I'm on bug duty
let's do it
ride ain't over yet my man
Justice League rated pg-13 experience
hey everybody we got a whole bunch of
new Justice League footage to break down
a shot of some of the ancient war
against Darkseid and Steppenwolf
involving some of the gods from the
Wonder Woman mythos if you saw the
Wonder Woman movie and you saw that pre
credits sequence where they explain what
happened to the gods and why she's one
of the only ones that's left this
footage implies that happened before
everything went to [ __ ] so I'll try to
explain the timeline but they just
announced that there's going to be a
Deathstroke spin-off movie so that also
answers some questions about what's
going on with him inside the DC EU
whether it be in the Batman movie or the
Justice League franchise they actually
just put tickets on sale for the movie
so that's what the giveaway is for all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this so Justice League footage first
they don't talk about the Deathstroke
movie because we only learned a couple
things about that like Joe Manganiello
will be staying on for that so the
really big stuff here first there's
stuff set in the flashbacks like when
they tell the story of what happened the
first time with the mother boxes they
haven't given a date for this but it's
at some point before Wonder Woman's
birth so it's before Ares revolts and
kills the rest of the gods the thing
that really tips the hat to this is that
this arc blast is exactly like the arc
blasts from the gods and Wonder Woman so
there's any confusion about how that
works it's just part of their abilities
like Wonder Woman can generate lightning
on her own they explained at the end of
the Wonder Woman movie so just careful
for spoilers for the Wonder Woman movie
if you haven't seen it yet is that she
fights Ares and it's almost like she
absorbs some of his energy and then
blasted back at him they explained that
that has nothing to do with the
gauntlets that she wears she actually
just generates that herself she is a
living God on the earth or if you really
want to get technical you say she's a
demigod because she's a daughter of Zeus
genuine father of the gods in Hippolyta
the queen of the Amazons so she's kind
of like 3/4 God the way they said
Superman up to is that he's sort of a
living God on earth just because of his
power levels but in that scene where you
see areas going around killing all the
other gods you learned that all of the
gods have the ability to generate those
lightning blasts so think of it as
magical lightning because the gods are
somewhat mystical but a lot of that
tends to flow
from real-world believes so it's kind of
the same thing in the comics to the gods
of Wonder Woman not quite the same thing
as the new gods of apocalypse and new
Genesis
we've talked about this fight from
different angles we've just never gotten
a really really good look at it in the
other members of this army here like we
got the behind the scenes shot of King
at land wearing the old armor that
Aquaman then goes back to Atlantis to
grab and his trident so in present day
when Wonder Woman is talking to Batman
about the Age of Heroes needing to come
again this was the first time that it
came you kind of get a look for the
different members here like you have
some Chinese warriors here you have
Atlanteans you have Amazons so there's
no way to confirm which God this is with
us Ares whether it's Zeus but I think
the idea is is they got just the
greatest heroes from everywhere
collected them to fight off this threat
so the assumption is is that would be
Zeus so you have to assume that this
went down
then Ares revolted against man Zeus used
the last of his magic and his life force
to help create the mascara in Wonder
Woman and then you pick up with the
beginning of the Wonder Woman movie but
we know we go back to the mascara and
what looks like present day so it'll be
interesting to see if she has a meeting
with Hippolyta and she tells Wonder
Woman about what happened during the
original war like oh yeah
it was this big thing aliens from outer
space came to turn the world into a
living hell
into another version of apocalypse but
probably the coolest new thing is the
way they cut Mira's aqua Kinesis ability
to the music where she claps her hands
together if you're not really familiar
with the comics if you remember Avatar
The Last Airbender how they had water
benders that could just control water
that's basically what Miura has in the
DC Universe is called aqua Kinesis so it
seems like we'll get a cool teaser for
her abilities when Steppenwolf comes to
Atlantis to try and grab their mother
box but I'm guessing they're gonna save
a lot of the really cool stuff for the
Aquaman movie next year but probably the
even bigger reason why I wanted to make
this video is because of the Deathstroke
announcement so people have been
wondering since they confirmed the
Deathstroke was going to be at DC EU
character Ben Affleck released that
teaser where they were just testing the
motion capture footage would he pop up
during the Batman movie because the
rumor was when Geoff Johns and Ben
Affleck were still working on the script
for the Batman movie it was going to be
something in a tone of the raid
redemption
this Indonesian martial arts film which
is basically a group of police officers
finding their way hardcore up to the top
of this high-rise so the rumor was is
that Batman was gonna go into Arkham and
it was going to be just like that so
people were like great that sounds like
a badass movie it's not too big it's
relatively self-contained Deathstroke
can be a part of it because they didn't
visioned him is sort of this darker
parallel of Batman more morally
ambiguous even though I don't totally
agree with that assessment of his
character that was a couple years ago
then you have all the craziness with
them sort of re-engineering how DC
Comics and Warner Brothers make their
movies Geoff Johns is elevated they sort
of changed their slate a little bit they
get their creative in order behind the
scenes they hired Matt Reeves to do that
Batman movie and as part of his producer
deal he got the right to rewrite the
script so whatever it was the geoff
johns and ben affleck had envisioned for
that batman movie that's not gonna
happen so joe manganiello was like I
don't know if I'm still gonna be
Deathstroke in the DC EU but it seems
like the holding pattern is over and
they're just going to do a destro
spin-off film which honestly I think is
a better way to go like they're gonna
make their Batman movie it can be its
own thing even though it's still
relatively connected to the DC EU I know
there's a lot of confusion people have
given a lot of conflicting reports about
what's going on with those new Batman
films but if you haven't seen it I
already did an explainer for how things
were reorganized at DC films in the
timeline of events and how that changed
I'll link that video at the end of this
it gets a little complicated but it's
really fascinating either way Joe
Manganiello is still a great actor he
could do a great version of Deathstroke
he's been training with swords ever
since they signed him to that deal so
it's been a couple years now but now it
sounds like they have the original
director of that Indonesian raid film
going to do the Deathstroke film so they
might actually pick up on some of the
ideas of that original Batman film and
use it for the Deathstroke movie but we
don't really have any idea what the
story is going to be where it's going to
be set in the timeline and how it's
going to integrate with the other DC
film so there's going to be any sort of
connective tissue think about it this
way Deathstroke is probably the best
chance you have for an r-rated DC film
now they have said some things about
Justice League dark maybe being r-rated
but I think that just depends I think
that'll be DC's first genuine
horror film but let me know in the
comments what do you think about the new
footage what do you think about this
Deathstroke movie what do you want them
to do with it if you haven't seen the
raid movie it's a really badass so watch
that and then imagine that with the
Deathstroke character but a lot of you
have also asked me about the runtime for
Justice League they just confirmed that
it's a hundred in 19 minutes which is
basically an hour and 59 minutes like
right under two hours
but because tickets are on sale now I'll
say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner Josh West please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for that
explainer video about what's going on
with the DC EU and how it's being
changed for the future and you can click
here for brand new flash footage thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight